yeah here we are again against Yardbird
let's see what we get here hmm not the
Pogo again we my transpose though but i
just want if something else yeah to get
get you updated statistically um this is
the 42nd game of our of our match here
and I'm down by 2 17 wins 19 losses six
drawers and early d5 interesting not
sure what I want to do there yeah we got
into something that is looking really
strange to be to be a 2 BM perfectly
honest a very strange kind of position
out of the two nite sting we played with
a 3 there and yeah that's interesting
yeah is ready to play five and if I go
if I've myself he might play c5 hmm what
a strange position okay maybe back you
can go in 5 i'm not sure how good it is
but it's definitely a possibility
'if 45 destroying my structure there
okay like 90 x 90 XD takes Queen d8 not
sure how bad this is I don't don't think
it's that terrible okay so going Bishop
g7 now now maybe if I have no he doesn't
want to it doesn't really want to go
there very interesting position
unconventional with deep on trade it
against F porn I would like to get
something going on the dark squares yeah
like putting something on d4 would be
excellent but it's not clear if I manage
that 83 and 84 was a was definitely am
possible at him I can do this however
going for night f4 maybe this is an idea
go trying that
yeah he doesn't take I wonder I can take
on see three years as an idea or is this
completely bonkers more interesting it's
interesting let's let's try it the movie
5 is the problem here if he is not going
45 now I'm certainly okay I think be
five if I might have night a form that
could be an idea yeah that's definitely
the critical move if I take um I don't
like that so neither for that's
interesting actually activating the
night and term getting out of this would
be to thing okay so i was thinking i
just take with them I could take with
the pawn it's not terrible what cheek
with the Queen it's also not it not not
bad mmm he's got to see five then okay
let's stick with that maybe you can take
and play Queen d2 for a 10 point then
worked you one hmm that can be a problem
no it's not doing that
okay let's do this 4p should be six
so he wants to try to play against this
night somehow but it's not so easy I
move like windy too as answer tlk can do
that Queen g5 is not possible
unfortunately he's up for night before
here in this position can i play I'd
like to do something aggressive their
queen edge from g3 night h4 King edge 2
is possible however hmm 94
okay difficult and I'm far too slow him
trying for counter check against c4 but
don't know if that's really possible I
couldn't really calculate this I can
just blundering stuff I'm just
blundering him ah bad bad bad bad bad no
I didn't even use it Bishop takes e4 was
just winning of course knight takes
Bishop f4 and 25 check kills me okay so
I'm lucky in that I'm still alive
okay let's check that it's equal
material now night might come to be five
time warning I don't know still not not
easy to play this thing no night at six
check on playing like an idiot yeah I'm
really playing like a complete [ __ ]
what is this making it so easy for him
it's not good not good at all I'm just
playing on because I'm so disappointed
actually what am I doing here in this
games liking it very easy for him and
you really I mean it didn't even use my
mistakes I mean not not to the fullest
at least Jack can play the check them
yeah I can resign actually I mean I'm
even down on time him yeah right i won
let's play one or two more moose get a
spy chicken an idea for Jack that's made
up g4 made almost I can go ahead and
nike air for it's not made but it's very
close check yeah I don't know he's
taking a long time maybe asking himself
why I'm continuing yeah actually I'm
asking Black is the same question yeah
it was a terrible game I mean not not
initially I think I'm it was interesting
at first but I really didn't see
anything maybe it's just too early in
the day so this should be seven or
something I went here and here here
already can totally do tequila I can
just take and play Queen d5 when a piece
he didn't see that I went here went back
and I went here I went here now I'm
blundering a piece again why is he not
what is this not losing a piece I don't
see it check because of that okay that's
pure luck didn't see that he just took
them and now i'm still okay I'm it's
nothing really nothing happening here so
like any more fruit d 7 or whatever
there's nothing happening here
and I just I just I just play this
nonsense and usually under this that's
really bad ah what a bad game okay well
thanks for watching